Hey Youtubers, It's Charlie.
So this is gonna be my Flash E14 video:
"Fallout"
But they just announced the schedule is changing, so I'll try to explain that first.
In the promo for E15 of The Flash, they said it's not airing 'til March 17ᵗʰ.
That means 3 weeks with no new episode.
The reason they're doing that is probably to promote the premiere of "iZombie";
because iZombie is premiering on March 17ᵗʰ.
So they have this, ..."Bananas", episode of The Flash in order to help boost the numbers for iZombie.
Yes it sucks...but you can't blame them for wanting to use their most popular show to promote a new one.
And the good news is, is Arrow E15 will air without a break.
So this week we have Arrow E14.
Then E15, "Nanda Parbat", airs next week (then it also goes on break).
So Flash & Arrow will be 1* episode apart for a couple weeks, but they'll sync-up again before the finales.
So don't worry.
That's just 3 more weeks of The Flash tagged-on to when we normally would've ended.
Okay, so lots of big stuff to get through. Lots of Easter Eggs.
So let's just start with 'Top 5 Moments':
Careful fore spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet.
No. 5: Team Flash starts to understand the Firestorm Matrix.
The beginning of the episode picks up IMMEDIATELY after last week's episode.
So, whenever you're watching this in the future, just watch 'em back to back
and It'll be like a 2-hour episode.
The 1ˢᵗ half was all about introducing Firestorm.
2ᴺᴰ half all about understanding what it's gonna be like going forward.
So by the end of the episode they figure it out a little bit better, and they can coexist
inside the Firestorm Matrix as distinct personalities.
That 'floaty-head-voice' that you heard from Martin Stein?
...that's how it is in the comics.
A lot of the bickering they did is also from the Firestorm comics too.
(that's part of the dynamic between Ronnie Raymond and Martin Stein)
On to No. 4:
Iris West is going to start investigating Star Labs.
They just teased it in the episode, but what I feel like is gonna happen is Iris WILL learn Barry is the Flash by the end of the season.
She'll be investigating Star Labs because of all these mysterious metahumans; all this crazy stuff going on.
And as a consequence of that, she'll learn that Barry's "The Flash".
Eventually, what I'd like to see, is her become the focal-point of the battle between the Flash and the Reverse Flash.
And, possibly the creation of a 2ᴺᴰ Reverse Flash
I know in the promo for E15 we saw Harrison Wells use the Speed Force to split himself in two --
to make it appear like there were two of him
-- but I'm expecting ANOTHER Reverse Flash.
Like an 'Eddie Thawne' Reverse Flash to be created by the end of the season.
On to No. 3:
Harrison Wells helps General Eiling capture Martin Stein.
I saw a lot of people were confused about this on Twitter.
You know, "Why would Harrison Wells help* General Eiling, if he wants to help* Team Flash, and learn more about Firestorm?"
Well, really, it's that second thing.
I think he just wanted to learn more about the nature of Firestorm's powers.
I think he was telling the truth when he said,
"I don't understand how Firestorm works"
Knowing that he, AS the Reverse Flash, is weak against Firestorm's powers (like we learned in E09)
he prob'ly wants to learn as much as he can about him.
Supposedly Firestorm is gonna be back for the finale.
It hasn't been confirmed by the CW.
I don't know what he's gonna be doing.
I'm HOPING that the Reverse Flash uses Firestorm's powers to enact some plot.
...but he might just come back to help fight the Reverse Flash.
They wouldn't bring the character back just to have a pizza party with Team Flash;
so whatever's happening, Firestorm is important to the finale.
Moving on to No. 2:
Barry is going to use his knowledge of the past to try'nd save his mother.
So they're slowly pushing into time travel.
I like the way they compared 'Back to the Future' rules, and 'Terminator' rules.
Really what you need to watch out for, is, "Predestination Paradox":
Whereby, if he changes the past (if he saves his mother) it might prevent him from
ever becoming the Flash, and therefore being able to go back in time and save his mother.
If you've seen the animated movie, "Flashpoint", this is what it's all about.
Barry goes back. Saves his mother.
And it COMPLETELY messes up the timeline; everything goes bananas.~
(To make another Gorilla Grodd joke)
Just feel free to make any 'Grodd/Bananas' jokes you want throughout this video.
There was an earlier episode this season, where Joe tells Barry,
"You need to learn to live with the things that you can't change"
So, that's gonna be part of his arc this season:
Learning that he can't* save his mother.
...no matter how powerful he gets.
The same thing is true for the Reverse Flash in the comics:
The 'Professor Zoom' Reverse Flash.
He hates Barry Allen.
Wants to kill him.
But if he kills Barry Allen, then he'll never become the Reverse Flash in the future.
So both the Flash, and the Reverse Flash, are stuck in this causality loop.
And, my No. 1 Moment (obviously):
Not God...GRODD.
THE best end-credits scene ALL season.
Not only does Harrison Wells unmask himself to someone as the Reverse Flash
we also get to hear Grodd speak AND use his powers of mind control.
The TV show is playing a little bit with the origin stories.
Harrison Wells confirms that he is a metahuman.
But, technically, the Flash isn't a metahuman.
"Metahumans" (as the show defines them) were people that got powers because of the Dark-Matter Explosion.
The Flash and the Reverse Flash both got their powers from the Speed Force (and the Negative Speed Force).
Which is not part of the Dark-Matter in the comics.
But I think the show is just combining those things.
So.
Technically you could* call the Flash a metahuman.
This doesn't really change anything that we didn't already know about Harrison Wells.
Other than when he said,
"I take care of my own"
It's interesting to think that he is "protecting" the other metahumans.
Whenever we first got that Gorilla Grodd-flashback, it seemed like he cared for him (like he was trying to help him).
It humanizes him a little bit, but there's a very nefarious undertone.
It's like, "Yes I'm going to protect this Gorilla, but only so I can use him to do something really aweful".
And in the promo for E15, he basically calls Barry Allen, a 'surrogate son'.
In the comics, Professor Zoom---Eobard Thawne---isn't like that at all.
He's completely nuts.
He hates everyone.
So this is the show just softening that character and using some aspects from Hunter Zolomon's character
in the comics. So what you're getting is, an amalgam, of Reverse Flashes.
And eventually, when we get a 3ᴿᴰ Reverse Flash (when we get like our 'Eddie Thawne' Reverse Flash)
I think the same thing'll happen.
He'll ALSO be an amalgam of a couple of Reverse Flashes.
One of the biggest questions you guys had after last week's episode was,
"When is Team Flash gonna learn what Harrison Wells is doing (that he's the Reverse Flash)?"
And the promo for E15 seems like it totally answers that.
Meaning that there's like 8 episodes left in the season.
DOES that not get you SO FREAKING EXCITED for where they're going to take the show?
Lemme know though:
What was your favorite moment from the episode?
And here's my big question:
What do you think that Harrison Wells is going to do, once that he reveals himself to Barry, as the Reverse Flash?
It's definitely gonna break their relationship once Barry learns that he's the "Man in Yellow".
Remember what Harrison Wells said though (when he was talking about Firestorm):
"Accept each other"
"Accept the balance between you"
He was talking about Ronnie Raymond and Martin Stein accepting each other.
But, really, the double-meaning is the Flash needs to learn to accept the Reverse Flash.
Tom Cavanagh. Amazing actor.
He was really open during the TCA's earlier this year about how he built in double-meanings to each of his lines.
I know sometimes, when he says one thing it sounds like he might be dropping Easter eggs for something else.
...it's totally true.
He's doing that all the time.
So just remember that whenever you hear him saying something that sounds really suspicious.
Here are some of the really cool Easter Eggs that I found that I haven't already mentioned yet:
Both Martin Stein and Ronnie Raymond, when they're separated, heat up to about a 106°F (41°C) resting temperature.
Issue #106 of The Flash, was the debut of Gorilla Grodd.
Obviously we saw Gorilla Grodd, full on, at the end of the episode.
When Barry goes back into his old house and said,
"That mirror belonged to my Grandmother"
(Iris West-Allen)
Obviously she gets married to Barry Allen in the comics; they have children; their children have children.
SO Iris West-Allen becomes the grandmother of the 'Bart Allen' Flash.
In the episode, they're using the mirror to look into the past, but it's also an Easter Egg
for what's going to happen in the future, for the future of the Flash Lineage.
When Martin Stein talks about time traveling using a "highway" -- really that's the Speed Force (the Speed Force IS the highway).
Moving so fast that you punch a hole in the space-time continuum.
We're supposedly gonna get a teaser for that in E15.
But I have no idea what it's going to look like.
Caitlin mentions Jason Rush Again.
Jason Rush also become part of the Firestorm Matrix in the comics.
It seems like they're going to stick with Martin Stein and Ronnie Raymond---with that pairing---through S02.
They say that Ronnie is Caitlin's cousin from Coast City (that's obviously where Green Lantern's from).
I know we all want to see him on the show at some point.
Martin Stein talks to Harrison Wells and says,
"I should have spent my life trying to be the best husband I could for my wife."
I feel like that was a loaded moment because it makes you think of Harrison Wells' dead wife.
Which is prob'ly the reason he's trying to gain the powers of the Flash; so that he can go back in time and save his wife.
It's romantic, in a really pathological way.
This is a really funny one:
Ronnie Raymond etches the message into his arm so that it appears on Martin Stein's arm.
But instead of scratching the answer on HIS arm, Martin Stein just taps Morse Code.
The reason it's funny is because Ronnie didn't* need to cut himself.
He could've used Morse Code too.
When Ronnie says Martin Stein has a friend in Pittsburgh that can help 'em, it's actually and Easter Egg for the comics.
Ronnie Raymond, in the comics, is from Pittsburgh.
At the end of the episode General Eiling says,
"That voice in my head"
That's just a reference to Gorilla Grodd's powers.
He has powers of mind control.
Cisco says, "I bet you that's where they're keeping the aliens too"
That could've been an Easter Egg for Martian Manhunter, or Superman from Flashpoint.
If you guys did see any other Easter Eggs in the episode just write 'em below in the comments.
The only real Thumbs Down I had in the episode was the Iris West storyline.
I feel like it's really far behind. It's moving WAY slower than all the other storylines.
It's lagging behind...big time.
I feel like something really big is gonna have to happen in the next 3 or 4 episodes to bring Iris West to the forefront of the story.
That's probably gonna be the investigation into Star Labs.
So hopefully that'll happen sooner*, rather than later.
Candace Patton is a great actress.
But I feel like Iris West's character hasn't caught up with the rest of the show yet.
Since there's no new episode of The Flash next week, I'm just gonna do a bonus video.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Feel free to leave me any requests you guys want.
And, remember, new episode of Arrow tomorrow -- and another new episode of Arrow next week.
While you guys wait for that stuff, you can click here* to get ready for Arrow.
And, you can click here* to watch last week's episode of The Flash.
Thank you so much for watching.
So let's all high five. I'll see you guys tomorrow.
[Closed Captioning brought to you in part by the Justice League of America]